Molly sounds like that sweet young girl
next door, but her real name
is "E-X" or Ecstacy.
She's old, she's been around
the block, and she's not the nice
gal that you think she is.
Hey guys, Trace here for D-News. The club
drug, molly, has been in the news a lot
lately. What with Miley Cyrus and other popstars
are singing about it and 2 deaths at
E-Zoo in New York over labor day weekend.
But before we get too into this, I want to head
some of you off with a pass. Molly
is E, molly is ecstasy,
molly is MDMA.
Molly is a generic name for a powdered
or crystallized form of MDMA
or Methylenedioxymethamphetamine.
The U.S. drug enforcement administration
classifies it as a schedule one
substance, which means it is highly dangerous. Has
no acceptable medical use, and
possessing any amount of it is
illegal. And powdered, by the way,
powdered does not mean pure.
MDMA was created and patented in 1914,
and was famously used in 1970's
by psychotherapists due to the drug's strong
effect to lower inhibitions and anxiety.
In the 1980's, the drug, known as E
or X, began hovering around the house
club scene until in the 90's
it became...
clear that ecstasy was being cut with
things far more dangerous, addictive and toxic.
Now in the twenty-teens,
the drug has resurfaced as molly, and part
because of the concerted effort by the drug seller
to re-brand it as purer,
powdered form. Let me assure
you, scientists,
drug users, and drug dealers alike
have all gone on the record
to say no, that is not
true. MDMA is an
amphetamine or a stimulant, and a
hallucinogen. MDMA alters your brain's
neurochemistry, bonding with the structures
that release and absorb brain chemicals
associated with mood. So, serotonin,
dopamine and norepinephrine.
This immediately induces feelings of euphoria,
closeness, and diminished anxiety
peaking after an hour or two, and usually
lasting 4 to 6. Once people pass
their peak, some will hit more
and more to maintain that high.
After the flood of chemicals abate,
your serotonin receptors are just...
...worn out. This
is manifested by a depressed mood and
extreme fatigue, often a day or two
later. Outside of the brain
the chemicals cause the rest of your body to go into
overdrive, causing high blood pressure
and body temperature or hypothermia.
Which can then also cause kidney
and liver failure. Often people
on ecstasy drink lots of water, thinking their
biggest danger is dehydration, which
they're kinda right. That can be bad, but
too much water intake combined with
lots of sweating, causes blood sodium
and electrolyte levels to drop
resulting in confusion, delirium,
convulsions, and maybe even a
stroke. The icing on this happy little cake
is MDMA usually
is not sold by itself.
It's often cut with Ketamine, LSD,
speed, or anything
that you crush into a white powder.
In combination, these drugs are extremely
toxic to the human body. Now,
in its pure form
like actually its pure form, MDMA
is relatively safe as drugs go
but it can be habit
forming, because as your neurons become immune
to large amounts of serotonin, it requires
more drugs to get the same high.
Overall deaths from this ol' gal
are pretty rare. Though since
2004, the number of hospital visits
had more than double to about 20,000 a year
So, does knowing all of this make you think twice about
trying it. Let me know and thanks for
watching D-news today. Stay safe out there everybody